[Musique]
c'est une poubelle à l'envers j'ai pas
de tabou aujourd'hui ça brille ça fait
longtemps qu'on n'a pas fait un petit
sobre et dit il ya un truc qui me manque
avec lui confinement c'est d'acheter des
choses de base j'achète pas beaucoup de
choses du tout moi j'aime beaucoup les
objets de décoration alors je suis très
figurines d'ailleurs quand je vais au
japon c'est ce que j'achète en grande
partie je suis aussi vite fait dans les
vêtements genre j'aime bien acheté à
droite à gauche quelques de chartes
quelques trucs mais je suis pas plus que
ça un gars qui achètent des choses
en fait les derniers trucs que j'ai
acheté là pour vous montrer ses des
vieilles figurines dans les membres
darracq et au japon regardez comme ça
incroyable vieux manuels le vieux un
manuel
regardez c'est génial il a une cape
c'est un vieux vieux jouets il est cool
a vu qu'on voulait couler beaucoup de
sang bref ça me manque d' aller dans des
magasins et de découvrir des trucs de
déco un peu cool d'ailleurs dans le
genre j'adore les vidéos docteur nos
âmes et présente des objets un peu
insolite qui peuvent être des objets que
tu utilises en tant que décoration bref
le sabre est dit c'est dit gagnoa one
that et c'est 1er et 10 dans lequel
juste dégâts poste des trucs qui sont
cools et que tu vas avoir envie
d'acheter juste derrière alors attention
mais évidemment je suis je suis pas très
partisan de d'acheter plein de babioles
à droite à gauche dont sert jamais
vraiment quand j'achète un truc souvent
c'est d'adecco et du coup ça sert
presque ça décor mon appartement je vais
pas acheter des trucs qu'il sert werder
j'ai horreur de ça bref une photo à 3 60
degrés imprimé sur une sphère
je vois très peu l'intérêt je vois très
peu l'intérêt c'est cool c'est un peu
whaou mais c'est pas plus beau que ça et
je pense que quand tu as pris une fois
la sphère et que tu as fais ça tu ne la
reprendra plus jamais je suis dieu un
futur cette chose de permet de fermer
n'importe quelle porte à clé mais non
mais non ça permet d'avoir l'esprit
tranquille quand tu vas dans des hôtels
aux d'airbnb mes mecs ça m'aurait enlevé
tellement de stress lors de mon
adolescence tellement de stress en moins
si j'avais eu cet objet devenu un autre
homme [ __ ] mais les nouvelles
générations vous avez tellement de la
chance vraiment nous on a été nerveuse
et quoi ne pas pouvoir fermer notre
porte de chambre à clé une ça alors
c'est du ce et du charbon pour barbecue
voilà c'est un peu ça casse ambiance moi
je trouve plus qu'autre chose je suis
désolé mais un peu bas dans ce savon de
dun l'odeur de la poudre à canon du feu
de camp et du whisky
bon il ya un débat celui sur l'odeur du
feu de camp moi je trouve ça sublime
l'odeur boisé l'odeur fumée du feu de
camp je trouve ça trop bien j'adore mais
des vêtements qui s'enseigne ça je suis
à deux doigts d'acheter ce [ __ ] de
sabre hockey au canada à montréal
j'avais acheté des cure-dents aromatisé
au whisky tourbe et il y en avait des
fumées aussi genre au goût de feu de
camp quoi et je trouvais ça très bien
c'est mon seul côté mâle alpha tout le
reste je suis très peu alpha un livre de
toutes les couleurs imaginables
je suis daltonien
[Musique]
ses rollers pour genou
à grave grave il me les faut absolument
je bricole pas n'ont pas les couilles la
meilleure boule de neige ever ça ça s'il
ya ça dans toutes les boutiques
touristiques de la planète c'est pas
pour rien c'est qu'il ya un potentiel
que les gens aiment là dedans donc là il
suffit qu'ils aient un truc original et
on va péter un câble balle vouloir
[Applaudissements]
gâcher cette télécommande et une entrée
casque pour écouter la télé dans ton
casque super traducteur ça c'est génial
pour les personnes malentendantes en
fait tout simplement
moi j'ai mon grand père avant de décéder
il entendait plus trop et je vous parle
de ça c'était un genre 10 ans et il
avait dû acheter tout un truc pour
pouvoir juste écouter la télé dans des
écouteurs et ça me faisait trop de la
peine genre un truc tout est super
chiant plus non non il ya ça directement
dans les télécommandes papy c'est pour
toi ô alors là les jeunes papas et
mamans là c'est pour vous dans cette
tâche il ya un compartiment secret
directement sous le bouchon
ce qui fait qu'en buvant ils vont
d'abord boire le médicament avant que la
boisson principal atteignent leurs
lèvres ou sinon juste eu éduque ton
enfant et tu lui fais comprendre que
prend des médicaments c'est important
pour lui lorsqu'il est malade j'ai pas
d'enfant laissez-moi critiquer votre
manière d'éduquer en passant supérieur
powa attendait c'est un instrument qui
permet de fermer un sachet après l'avoir
ouvert quoi mais c'est génial mais ça
c'est le fossé genre de truc tu va
l'acheter en disant c'est génial et
ensuite tu vas jamais l'utiliser parce
que depuis vingt ans de ta vie tu
n'utilises pas et donc tu auras pas le
réflexe d'utiliser ça fait beaucoup de
fois le mot utilisé mais j'étais nul en
français de base en tant que grand frère
serait un super élément ajouté à mon
arsenal ça me fait sourire
ou bien trier d'en avoir un on dirait un
futur qui a mal tourné je les aimais
vraiment acheter un truc pour faire des
pichenettes qui font plus mal que les
pichenette normal enfin c'est grave
soyons honnêtes c'est grave et des
capsules établir comme ça les gens
trouveront que tu as mis vraiment
beaucoup d'efforts et d'énergie dans le
fait de trouver un truc pour décapsuler
de mahler style était bière et du coup
ça sera plus stylé en fait aux yeux des
gens un truc qui peut tenir ton écran
ouest seront comment c'est charles trop
encombrant j'achète je vais le réaliser
on va tous se ruiner la après cette
vidéo on va acheter tellement de trucs
dont va même pas servir s'il vous plaît
soyez sûr vous allez vous en servir
avant d'acheter quelque chose ne gâchons
pas ne poussons pas à couver à la
consommation inutile je suis culotté de
dire ça dans une vidéo je montre que des
gadgets inutiles
attendez quoi wwa est ce que ça marche
vraiment s quoi met à tomber le gars il
avait quand même moustique nous est pas
possible c'est un moustique qui a acheté
ça pour tuer ses potes moustiques mais
jamais été autant de moustiques c'est
vraiment une pub ça n'arrive jamais du
sein avec du propre retour ça n'existe
pas personne ne se salit comme ça vous
comprenez vous attendez j'aimerais bien
savoir si ça marche parce que ça c'est
vraiment les conneries là où il ya des
pubs sur wii je pensais truc là et tu
l'achète et quand tu ouvres le
compartiment toi ya zéro moustiques je
me méfie à mort de ces trucs
technologique soit disant je sais pas
quoi j'ai fait des remakes mais doit
désabonnez vous tout de suite cette
étagère
le déni sommes en étagères elle souffre
comme ça je pas comme tout le monde
et ben non il ya des étagères ikea comme
tout le monde et ça marche très bien ok
je suis un gros rageux attendant là par
contre là par contre ya plus aucune
grille
[Musique]
chaque mois où j'avais acheté à l'époque
des trucs d'espèces d'autocuiseurs tu
mets dedans tu lance un programme chez
pas quoi ça ne marche jamais fait en
tout cas j'avais pas le faire marcher je
pense c'est plutôt ça la mecque ça
ajoute progressivement étape après étape
c'est incroyable sans même que tu as
besoin de te lever et de rajouter
manuellement mais le niveau de
flemmardise pour avoir ça est équivalent
au mien je veux olala ça a l'air
incroyable rush est non mais là c'est
pire ce que je vous ai dit c'est mon
péché mignon ce genre de truc tu vois ça
reste une langue ça va toujours tout
servir une lente mais celle là elle est
lé concept elle est belle et elle est
cher et ça c'est cher plus tard
cette clé pas pratiquer pratiquer je
préfère un gros ou plus de la clé plutôt
que tp c'est galère la tournée là je dis
je dis ce que je pense et moi je dis
tout haut ce que tout le monde pense
tout bas
et si on roulait à ça s'apparente ça par
contre l'eau chaude c'est lumine donc
c'est beau et en plus quand tu regardes
l'un des deux talent effet portal bah
voila quoi vous ai compris moi
jean-jacques une pochette infini pour
toutes les choses dont je n'ai pas
besoin
olala ça casse la tête
oh là là oh là là je suis à deux doigts
de lâcher un j'achète c'est un vide
poche mais optimisé que pour les choses
plate jeunes calais
j'ai un qr code où j'avais un qr code ça
donne quoi
c'est rick roll au mois on est en 2008
on en a bon ça c'est un gant de moto qui
te protège des coupures et du feu c'est
des gamins destructive haut à comment je
ferais jamais ça ne fait pas ça même si
vous avez un gant si vous ne faites pas
ça ouah tam et hummer gacaca et des
gangs aux îles élite rien faire conclut
quoi à laquelle tu te plaît là aux déçus
on connaissait le canapé convertible
mais est ce qu'on connaissait le canapé
lit superposé convertibles pas du tout
cet oreiller
écoutez je n'avais jamais compris le
délire du traverse pour moi c'est juste
un truc qui élève un peu trop ton
oreiller
ce qui fait complètement celle là a
traversé un plus long avec des angles
qui peut se plier un peu lâche comprend
l'intérêt il m'a fallu 24 heures pour
comprendre l'intérêt c'est bon une
chaise pour les gens qui adorent être
assis avec les jambes croisées mais
c'est mon rythme mais qu en ce moment je
suis tout le temps comme ça pas en vidéo
jeune je me tiens tu vois c'est un peu
comme un repas de avec ma belle famille
tu vois je fais genre et je suis bien
j'ai fini tournée je suis comme ça j'en
ai rien à [ __ ]
paris n'a pas de dossier donc bon il
faudrait la même chose avec un dossier
mecque et ces gens leur rêve
mettez un dossier est franchement
jacques et bien écoutez c'est la fin de
cette vidéo qui nous aura honteusement
tous pousser à la consommation j'adore
ces trucs au design raffiné ses petites
idées par ce pas là tous les gars qui
design des choses et qu'ils pensent à
prendre un truc tout con du quotidien
elle cette époque je trouve ça
incroyable incroyable et est un trop
grand mot mais en tout cas ça
m'intéresse d'ailleurs j'ai toujours
cherché des endroits des boutiques un
peu style et où ils vendent des trucs un
peu originaux comme la chaise pour tu
vois à s'asseoir les gens croisés un des
objets de déco un peu cool un peu
originaux aussi fin j'ai du mal à
trouver des boutiques qui vendent des
trucs un peu de déco cool comme ça et
qu'il soit pas juste que des trucs made
in china fait en quantité astronomique
et qui rien d'original quoi bref
j'espère que ça vous a plu
c'est toujours très intéressant de
trouver ces petits trucs de déco un peu
originaux mais ça fait plaisir et j'ai
l'impression que plus le temps passe et
plus il ya des gars qui se met à faire
ça en fait à design et des trucs un peu
cool à le faire même
annuellement en édition limitée et où je
trouve ça vraiment cool ce truc de la
création autour des objets tout ça
vraiment sympa mais je souhaite plein de
belles choses je vous dis à très vite je
m'en vais m'asseoir à l'ara chemin dans
la vie sophie à bientôt
[Musique]